hallo liebe leute herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen episode the german bayern
sind heute abdul und aller von gs german
life style und wein aus schottland der
spontan als wie sie den zuschauer dazu
kommen ist wer heute mal ein ernstes
thema für euch und zwar möchten wir von
den deutschen wissen was würden sie
machen wenn sie aus ihrem land fliehen
müssten
warum stellen wir diese frage aller ja
wir hatten dieses schlechte erfahrungen
eigentlich vorher vielleicht drei vier
jahren und wir mussten uns alle unser
land verlassen
es war sehr traurig genau wie syrien war
sehr emotional traurig und wir werden
dort fragen was würden sie tun wenn sie
an unserer stelle wären
los geht's
was würden sie machen wenn plötzlich in
deutschland krieg herrscht oder
vielleicht ein anderes ein politischer
unterdrückung und sie das land verlassen
müssten
ein szenario dass mir gar nicht
vorstellen möchte es ist eine
katastrophe ist wenn man freunde
verliert man verliert die heimat
eventuell für jegliche grundlage zum
leben keine ahnung wie ich mich dann
verhalten würde könnte ich mir das nicht
vorstellen so will ich gar nicht
vorstellen
aber wenn dann natürlich wieder weggehen
sagen wir so es herrscht hier in den
krieg und bomben fallen jetzt überall
was würden sie dann in solchem fall
machen
wegziehen woanders hingehen wo anders
hin nach australien wo australien weil
mein bruder lebt
ok
krieg in deutschland
grausam
grausam also ich denke immer nur daran
unsere eltern oder deren eltern haben ja
auch vieles mitgemacht
in ihrer zeit in ihrer nachkriegszeit
und ich meine da waren sie natürlich
dankbar für alles was den entsprechend
auch entgegengebracht wurde
auch da war ja das thema
willkommenskultur für sie eine ganz
wichtige erfahrung diese machen mussten
ich würde mal gucken in welchem land
aktuell eine demokratie herrscht und
dahin dann aus wenn denn wahrscheinlich
in die schweiz schätze ich was ich
machen würde
ich hoffe dass ich vorher schon weg bin
also ich würde ich würde woanders hin
nach la gomera la gomera
ich würde ins ins benachbarte ausland
für ihn tatsächlich also noch holland
nach frankreich
je nachdem wo kein krieg wäre würdest du
hingehen
da wo man aufgefangen will vielleicht
alsbald er auch schon wo man hilfe
bekommt wo würden sie hingehen
frankreich in frankreich gibt es
leckeren käse wenn sie da willkommen
ein flüchtling es nirgendwo willkommen
vermutlich zumindest weil ich dem staat
oder den land menschen nichts geben kann
so das gefühl wird ich haben manche
leute werden wir das gefühl geben und es
wird zum büfett stärken
ich werde nicht wissen ob ich wirklich
willkommen denn so wie es um den
flüchtlingen heute auch hier geht werde
ich so fahre ich glaube unser land wo
ich frieden erwarte also dass er auch
anhält deswegen wahrscheinlich kader
oder island oder er kommt drauf an wo
kein krieg ist vielleicht irgendwie in
den norden hoch ich weiß nicht und was
würdest du mitnehmen
bei familie freund- und geld was ich
mitnehmen würde mein handy das alles
drin was ich brauche was würdest du
mitnehmen
meine familie sonst nichts
alles andere braucht man nicht mit die
beiden auf jeden fall und vielleicht
noch zwei koffer also klamotten geld
smartphone solche sachen und gibt was
das so dass ihr mitnehmen wartet also
meine frau und mein sohn auf jeden fall
also meine familie und gegenstände
wahrscheinlich erinnerungen mein handy
geld
gute güte meine familie ein telefon so
viel geld wie möglich kommt darauf an
was die umstände zulassen ob ich mein
auto fliegt oder irgendwie sich in der
bahn drängelt dann also viel wie möglich
so viel wie nötig seien noch etwas
hat ihre am liebsten meine familie und
meine bücher und meine freunde schätzen
und was würden sie von menschen erwarten
die in dem land sind wo in sibirien wird
dass sie mich aufnehmen
wir natürlich das freundlich sind dass
ich mich aufnehmen dass sie mir helfen
und was was würdest du erwarten in
kanada oder island
ich glaube dass ich meinen beruf machen
könnte und dass ich ein schönes zuhause
habe und irgendwie schön und gut
integriert werde
und ja mich da einfach irgendwann auch
zu hause fühlen kann und nicht die ganze
zeit an deutschland denke ja dass sie
uns aufnehmen dass sie nicht aggressiv
gegenüber uns sind oder so abwertend
sind dass sie einfach nett sind
können sie sich vorstellen wie die leute
die je nach deutschland kommen
wie die das empfinden dass sie erleben
den heimatlos den fehlt einfach jegliche
bindung und komme ich auch merkels satz
zurück willkommen weil das ist
wenigstens etwas womit man eine freude
machen kann für denjenigen der hierher
kommt seine heimat verloren hat seine
familie verloren hat schreckliches
erlebt hat hierher kommt und da sagt
jemand hier bist du willkommen
das gab gehabt hab ich kein flüchtling
bis jetzt gehabt der willkommen war egal
im zweiten weltkrieg ob die deutschen
waren die flüchten mussten
die waren auch in frankreich nicht
willkommen das sollte man heute
zumindest anders machen
liebe leute das war unsere einzige
episode mit dem thema was würdet ihr
machen
in euroland krieg wäre jetzt machen wir
von euch wissen was würdet ihr machen
also schreibt uns das mal in die
kommentare
wie würdet ihr euch fühlen wo wir
hingehen was würdet ihr mitnimmt danke
aktuelle und aller dass er dabei war
ihr solltet unbedingt mal bei gls
reinschalten und gucken was die beiden
so wie youtube machen wo finden sie auf
youtube
wie heißt das schreibt man einfach
youtube direct lifestyle die lsg
lifestyle wenn ihr mehr sehen wollt über
witzige unterschiede zwischen der
deutschen und jüdischen kultur wie man
in deutschland lebt wie man sie am
besten integriert alles über die
deutschen kultur
danke rein auf das du dabei warst wir
haben uns sehr gefreut und wenn ihr lust
habt easyjet zu unterstützen werden wir
uns sehr freuen werdet mitglied bei
fashion subscribe und gibt uns einen
daumen nach oben dankeschön nach unten